i want to pull up this story from the
hartford current
robert reich up at the truth about
america's second civil war and the truth
is as he puts it is that it's not going
to be a civil war it's going to be a
slow peaceful breaking apart of you know
people slowly deciding not to work with
each other but maintaining things like
the common defense or whatever so just a
moment ago you mentioned you know the
potential for civil war whatever i read
this article it's from may 10th and the
fascinating thing is that when you
actually read the history of the
american civil war
robert reich clearly did not
this dude because if he did his his
op-ed would not say we won't go to civil
war his op-ed would be like yeah it's
going to happen
he's basically saying that there's a
disagreement on laws there's a
disagreement on how to run things so
people are deciding to hyper polarize
red you know republicans move to red
states democrats to blue states and then
ultimately we're just going to decide to
you know just do our do our thing
yeah read about the civil war that's
what was happening southern states were
saying that the northern states were in
violation of federal law because they
were supposed to be returning slaves and
they weren't and if that was the case
why would they have to abide by federal
law if the north wasn't doing it if
california right now is not enforcing
immigration law why then should you know
texas
enforce federal abortion standards this
is what precipitates the breaking apart
of the union like we saw in 1860.
then you had seven states secede before
abraham lincoln was inaugurated and then
after
there was a few more states i think that
joined in i think it was seven states
then when the uh battle of fort sumter
happened a bunch of other states went
whoa
like yo count me out like this is crazy
the union is going in now and their
states are supposed to be sovereign
robert reich is saying you know there's
an abortion issue is happening so
democrats are going to move to blue
areas and republicans to red areas and
i'm like yeah that's literally what's
happening
so when you have roe v wade and then you
get republican states basically saying
like we're not doing it anymore we're
gonna start you know and they get sued
over it
it's the lawsuits that brought us to the
point where roe v rowe and casey may now
be overturned
but then the the democrats are gonna be
like republicans aren't abiding by by
the the laws of this land and it's like
dude california and new york allowing
non-citizens to vote you kidding me it's
not just one one thing happening in one
area it is
democrats in the entirety of california
according to i can't remember which ngo
it was earned one extra electoral
college vote and congressional seat by
allowing illegal immigrants into the
state without enforcement because uh
congressional seats are apportioned
based on population size not citizenry
right all of this stuff it's it looks
very eerily reminiscent to what happened
in
you know how much it cost a week
president
maybe donald trump gets in and
you know much it costs every californian
every year to for illegal immigrants in
the states 1800
median for every single household in the
state i mean it's getting to a point
where the people that are fed up and the
left will continue to do whatever they
want they don't care about the standards
of federal law or what they're supposed
to do and then as soon as a conservative
or republican president or republican
governor comes out and does something
like this then it's the end of the world
for them i mean that's conservatives
have to play hardball i mean i'm the
biggest fan of desantis because what
he's doing because he doesn't care at
all what the left thinks about him he
doesn't care about the political
standards that we're supposed to live by
he uses the power that he has and he
gets things done in a way that no other
republican governor has really done in
recent memory have you seen the left
they'll say like republicans are
steamrolling democrats because they're
too weak have you seen that rhetoric
it's amazing
so
to the left if they don't get everything
they want republicans are steamrolling
them to the right if they only concede a
little bit they're doing all right yeah
that's the amazing thing the republicans
are like well we're going to give the
democrats what they want you know you
got mitch mcconnell they're not talking
about red flag laws no and i'm just like
yo there's no there is no right in this
country there there's none i love the la
i'm i'm being somewhat facetious the
left says there is no left in this
country every single politician is far
right oh okay name the politician who
just stood up and said in the wake of
what we've just seen in this country
it's time to repeal the nfa it is time
to repeal all gun laws as infringements
and violations of the constitution not
not sorry it doesn't happen you got a
handful of republicans who talk about it
where some people i think have proposed
bills but the republican party is not
going out saying repeal gun laws
the democrats are saying ban guns i'm
not saying that every democrat is saying
ban all guns i'm saying they have quite
literally banned a ton of them they now
want to ban assault weapons which is
meaningless where is that where the
republican party to come out stand up
and yell we have to unban selective fire
rifles
no because there is no right there is a
slow down there democrats and then
democrats that's what we have the speed
limit is conservatives are just leftists
driving the speed limit yeah that's
essentially what it is every time you
give the lift an inch they take a mile
the only reason why we are in this
situation is because conservatives
historically have been so weak to not
let anything happen and this is kind of
my gripe with libertarianism that kind
of got me in trouble on the michaela
peterson podcast when i talked about
this which i'll say again because i
think anyway libertarianism in in
essence is you know it's the kind of
liberal
uh
answer of saying you know if it happens
to someone else's home then it's fine uh
whatever happens outside there it's okay
that's kind of the libertarian answer i
don't want other people to get involved
in my life
and as soon as you have that again
pitted up against the ideology of
leftism that is revolutionary in its
essence then you get a society that
continually gets steamrolled by these
types of people so if you have these
like classical liberal types and i don't
know exactly where you guys are but you
have these classical liberal types that
say live and let live the left will
steamroll you every time because you
continue to give up things to them yes
the party that just wants to be left
alone will always lose always wants to
win where's what we're seeing this is
what i love to say to my owner friends i
don't care if they're the left
anarchists don't believe right-wing
anarchists exist
and i think it's really funny denying
their existence they do they do they're
like you can't be a capitalist and an
anarchist it's like you can you know but
sure whatever but i'd like to just say
where's the great anarchist civilization
sorry there isn't one i mean there was
like a brief period in catalonia where
there was like an arctic state or
whatever you've got some parts of mexico
today but the reality is that without a
centralized authority you get
steamrolled by authoritarians who
exploit your your
for the most part peaceful nature
this is what it really bugs me too about
conservatives anarchists are not violent
and i say this to all of his people on
the political compass memes subreddits
and things like that they're like
libertarian left and they show antifa
and i'm like dude you can't be
libertarian and violently beat someone
with a bike lock into submission so they
do what you want politically that is
authoritarian you are like adhere to the
authority or i will beat you that is not
libertarian left libertarian are like
hippies on a farm sharing their
watermelon right libertarians are the
farm you know one town over that's
selling the fertilizer to the hippies in
exchange for watermelon
but people don't understand that they
think left libertarian in the political
spectrum is like woke people no no no no
no woke is authoritarian left yes we
will destroy your life unless you adhere
to our ideology you do not see left
libertarians all that often you just
don't
i'm thinking about like the people
sitting still maybe the libertarians
people that don't want to be bothered by
the outside world they'll be surrounded
rooted out and destroyed usually by a
stronger state force so the romans the
way they figured out was we're just
gonna kill and subjugate our neighbors
so that no one can come and take us but
that's the imbalance that's like the
authoritarian imbalance at some point
it's state versus state whether that's
your house and his house
you both have your doors locked you
maybe you know each other maybe you
share keys but i doubt it and like so
where do you go where do you fall in the
balance of state power
i'm i'm actually more of uh i think the
state could actually do more in some
ways and less than others i mean i i
think there's a lot i actually we took a
trip even in one of the first times that
we ever saw each other we went to
budapest and i gave a speech there and i
think that a lot of the things that
hungary is doing is actually quite
successful where they understand the
power that they have to make people's
lives better and they emphasize the
family and people are doing pretty well
in hungary i mean they're having great
economic recovery and the family unit i
mean the child tax credit so you're
getting hungry like if you have up to
four kids you can get a free car from
the free car yeah you get a car from the
government in some ways a liberal
democracy is not a dirty word there
right exactly it's illiberal illiberal
yeah so that's the left today is
illiberal
right but what they mean by that is the
idea that you can have a democratic
society which i mean hungary is uh but
still not embrace liberal values you
know i'll tell you this communism
it works
i'm gonna wait so that people get pissed
off and then yeah i'll go for it
it works in two circumstances theory an
extremely small population like a family
itself where the dad is in charge and
gives everyone what they need to do
their thing but we wouldn't really call
that communism it's not communism it's a
commune right right but it also works
when you have an ideologically
homogeneous culture
you get a thousand people that all
blindly follow each other and agree with
their their cult ideology and you will
have this functioning society the
problem is communists always try to
enact that and there's only one way to
do it kill everyone who disagrees which
is why in reality communism never works
because
there are too many different ideas too
many different people they'll never
agree with each other unless you have
some weird small cult no what does the
left think democracy is the left thinks
democracy is when it's only their
opinion right everyone else's opinion
gets shut down the evil there's a
difference i'm not sure if you've read
the book jonathan hyde his book on uh uh
what's it called i can't remember the
book but essentially he does studies on
the difference between
the righteous mind yeah right i think so
yeah where people disagree yeah yeah and
so conservatives their outlook on the
world believe that people are naturally
born not good and that we have to
overcome our bad natures to do good
things in society whereas leftists think
that okay people are actually born good
but there's a small group of evil people
that we have to take out so that we can
have this good society that's why you
hear conservatives call leftist
brainwash where leftists call
conservatives evil most of the time and
so that difference yeah now now the
right is calling the left evil yeah
which is good and right so yeah yeah we
should start yeah right a little bit
exactly like that difference
whenever i point out a periodically
we'll say like hey you know we invite
leftists on the show all the time they
don't come only a couple have ever come
i've done that and then i get these
prominent leftists we're like i'll come
on your show and i'm like awesome we
will pay your travel we'll get you the
fanciest hotel we'll have you you get a
limo whatever you want then they
privately message me saying i'm not
going to your show it's all performant
if it was all they wanted they want a
hoot and holler in front of their
followers like i'll do it and then
behind the scenes say oh you know i
can't sorry it won't happen
so i point out
whenever i say this what happens is the
prominent left personalities refuse to
do it no or they'll try and play this
dirty game where they'll be like i'd
absolutely love my appearance fee is 15
000 some nonsense no like trying to do
things knowing that we would not ever do
it so they can say we cancelled on them
or something
but then we get lower uh like people
with like a smaller body of work or less
followers and they'll be like i'll do it
and here's what here's what you realize
when you okay well we're gonna try and
be fair and have these people on they
have no idea what they're talking about
no you ask them to elaborate the ideas
they have no idea they'll say what i
don't understand huh what do you mean
and they'll just keep repeating slogans
the higher profile leftists
i believe for the most part they know
why not to engage with people who are in
the liberty side of things because it's
not all conservatives like you're you're
mentioning classical liberals i'm not i
don't i i've always considered myself
social liberal which is basically the
mirror image that's
centrist libertarian position sure
but we you know we have a bunch of
people on the show all the time we
disagree like sheamus is pro-life i'm i
would say more so pro-choice i hate
saying pro-choice because
the left is just
gone so crazy with it but we disagree
all the time
the more prominent leftists know they
can't actually come on this show because
they will be obliterated because their
ideas have no merit for the most part i
agree with some of left-wing you know i
ideas and stuff and i can argue that i
can agree with some of the criticisms
about you know unfettered markets and
things like that but when it comes to
facts is joe biden corrupt
yes
it is a fact that he went to ukraine and
threatened to withhold us aid in
exchange for the firing of a prosecutor
who happened to have been investigating
a company where his son worked i'm not
saying that's why he did it but
any politician going to a foreign leader
and saying i will unilaterally suspend a
u.s debt obligation to you
that's corruption
they accuse trump of doing that now if
you bring on one of these left
personalities they'll deny it they'll
say that never happened nope never
happened yeah i bring these people on we
show them the video and they're just
like what what about the steele dossier
yeah what about hillary clinton's role
in approving these things they don't
read the news it's tough because
eisenhower warned us about the liberal
economic order the military industrial
complex and was like yo they we just
built like a world police just so you
know and watch out because it's gonna
try and take over the country and it did
within like two years but it's like
culture shock people didn't know that
until about 12 years ago when the
internet appeared now we can study like
you know the federal reserve and the
military liberal economic order and so
they're like having cognitive dissonance
and when you if you really want to shake
someone off out of this like i don't
know if you call it leftism or what but
this liber this liberal
or the idea of just believing whatever
the establishment says i guess yeah i
feel like that's more how i go about
things now is divide people within the
the people who know and people who don't
know so to say because you're not i feel
like there's no way that you're gonna
wake someone up to the fact that there
are no 73 genders you know like if you
still believe that now or if that that
is your your world i'm i'm not going to
try and convince you that there are only
two sexes i i'm just i'm over that you
know that's done and i feel like most
conservatives should be more or less
done with that now i tweeted
simply neo pronouns are made up
because they literally are wait what is
a neo pronoun like z zemser oh but there
i don't even know what that is they're
literally made up and i don't mean that
in a disparaging way it's like people
sit down and then try and come up with
pronouns yeah so i just tweeted
neopronouns are made up because no one
disagrees and boy they got so angry at
me i'm always in the word neo new so it
must be they were just like everything's
made up of you idiot you [ __ ]
no but that's what they think that's
what they think they think that
everything is a social construct so of
course that's what they're going to say
to you words are made up right and and
words get meaning all the time
but it is not in dispute among the left
or the right that neo-pronouns are made
up right that's why i thought it was
funny to state something that was just
so obvious
and they got mad about it they think the
way you're saying it is disparaging in a
way that's also just you yeah
this is the funny thing i once
hassan [ __ ] once made a joke so i
screen grabbed and just reposted so i
thought the interaction was funny and
then he responded as though i didn't
understand his joke
like the the the the assumption is
always adversarial it's because your
twitter picture you look mad if you were
happy and laughing in your twitter
picture people would think that things
were typing were happy you know what i
should do i respond to people like these
leftist personalities all the time
either to agree with them on certain
issues and like not approach them in an
adversarial way but their followers do
not like it i think it's hilarious i
mean like twitter it's worth yeah the
worst you get way more negative replies
on twitter than positive replies most of
the time what's text in general there's
no context yeah most people in their own
bubbles will get their own bubble yeah
but i'll see like vosh tweet something
and if he says something and i i'll like
if i say if he says something i agree
with about guns or whatever then i'll
respond
affirmatively and his followers are just
like now you can't agree that's not
allowed yeah it's like everyone ever
dude thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you